hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're going to be talking about
which
is better a startup or a big company
so let's figure that out starting with
the day-to-day that you can expect of
these two types of companies
starting with a startup with a startup
you can expect to do many different
things and not just your duties as
a developer or as an engineer you'll be
expected to
help out in marketing you'll be expected
to assist
in design to assist in some admin work
it really
is not just you doing the coding and
then someone else doing something else
you'll be touching the different parts
of the business
now this can be very good for people who
get bored easily or people
who want to learn different parts of
your business maybe you're looking to
one day create your own startup create
your own business this is a great way to
know what goes
into that however there are long hours
you can expect longer maybe not long
long depending on the startup but you
can expect
longer hours than that of a
large corporation because you're
touching all these different things
you are gonna have to stick around
longer if the site crashes
then it's you has to wake up at 2 am to
get the code base running again
and make sure things are good there's
not all these different people who can
do that job
when you're not at the desk and so that
is where things can get tricky now going
to a larger company
you definitely will have more of a
likelihood
of having the straight eight-hour
workday 40 hours a week and not needing
to
extend your hours or be in all these
different roles
you can expect to have one job and one
job only one
project you're working on for a year one
feature you're working on
and that is that this can be great for
people who like to know
what their day will look like who get
anxious i know me i get anxious
wondering what tomorrow holds and of
course there's you know elements of that
but
in terms of what you're responsible for
what is expected of you that doesn't
really
change now where things can get tricky
is you could get bored easier because
you're doing this one
thing and also you are working on an
already existing project likely if it's
a big company it's probably been here
for decades
the project and the product you're
working on has been here
long before you were here and you'll be
here long after
you're gone so it's less
innovative i'd say you feel less
innovative you're working on maintaining
code
and you're working on fixing bugs and
maybe
making processes better or faster so it
can be less
innovative because of that however with
this you'll get to
know one thing really well so it can be
very great professionally now going into
pay and benefits so with a large company
you can
expect a better amount of cash
coming your way just in terms of base
pay
and bonuses however
i'm not really sure to be honest who
wins
in this category startup or
large company and here's why with a
startup
where they make up for their probably
lower base pay is with their stock
options
especially if they are private if
they're a small company odds are they
are private
now why is this important stock options
when a company goes
public you can end up very rich very
fast
because you are able to get
stock at a discount and now that the
company is public
all these people are getting their stock
the stock is much higher
and now you are able to get
compensation in the form of stock in
like
a crazy like three-fold four-fold
eight-fold amount
so here's a funny example of this so you
can really get what i mean
so when facebook bought whatsapp the 55
employees that worked for whatsapp they
got
three billion dollars to split between
them
with the early developers employees that
were with them from day one day to day
three
getting up to 150
million dollars
yeah yeah so that's what i mean when we
say when i say
i don't know which is better now
i'm not saying to go to a startup so you
can become a billionaire and then so
don't be coming at me when you don't get
millions a few
years in like that is not what i'm
saying the facebook example
is an extreme example but it just
illustrates my point
you get a lower base pay but you get
stock options and if your company
is bought by a much larger company
or they go public so they can now be you
know
traded upon you know the stock exchange
and you know you can go on robin hood
and get some stock
then your compensation package looks
a lot better on top of this there are
also little tiny
trinklets of benefits here and there
with startups
like being able to like drink at work
like there are so many startups around
me
where there is a fridge full of beer and
you know
salsas and wines and you can just chill
like
your clothes like you can come up in
here with your sweats and your loafers
and
go to work it is so chill and relaxed
and so that can be a big benefit for
people in terms of their
lifestyle at work at big companies
like let's say you're a software
engineer at a bank odds are there will
still be some type of
restrictions in terms of dress code for
you i know when i
worked at a bank this software engineer
still looked pretty relaxed
i was actually pretty shocked to be
honest be me and my you know
accountant finance mind and everything
but um
there you can expect just more
restrictions than
a startup however with a large company
there are also you know more chances for
like large events galas
if holiday parties and all the works
having food
paid for and everything every single day
at your office and
just increased convenience so
that's why i say with yeah a in terms of
salary and things and benefits
it's a toss-up it kind of depends how
long you're looking to
stay at that company what things are
most important to you do you
need that base pay or are you able to
stick it around for five
years to see if your company gets
acquired or gets that ipo next we're
going to talk about community
it's probably not a shock that with a
startup you can expect a more
tight-knit group you can expect feeling
more like a quanko
family i personally that is a red zone
word for me
in terms of companies calling themselves
families that's a conversation for a
different day
but it can feel just more tight-knit
more like a
closed community you know the people
you're working with you probably
will know more of the people in the
entire company
than you would a large company on top of
that
with a startup you have much more access
to higher ups you can have access to the
ceo the ceo
the your senior managers you
your boss himself could be the ceo
i have friends where this is their
situation and so
in terms of learning and development it
can be very inspiring to be around those
people and to learn from those people
again
especially if you are looking to have a
company for yourself in the future
now when it comes to a large company
odds are you won't know
most of the people you will probably
just know your team in terms of
very very closely you will know your
team and maybe a few people here and
there outside of it but
that's kind of it if you want to know
more people outside of your team
then you're going to have to put in that
legwork of going to the happy hour going
to
so and so event going to so-and-so
soccer tryouts like you like you have to
put in more work
but it can also be really nice knowing
that on any given day
you'll meet five to ten new people
maybe in terms of really meeting like
talking to them like five to ten more
people maybe you're very outgoing you
can meet 100 people a day
but yeah getting to know that you will
always be meeting someone new from
different teams different operations
different lines of business that can be
very exciting for some
where some people with small companies
startups
they don't like the idea of after
30 days you know everything about
everybody and it is just all all the
time and you don't meet anyone new and
all of that so
it depends on the person you are i
mentioned that with the startup you have
more access to higher ups
with a big company you have also
very great access to robust and
structured
mentoring opportunities many times when
you're new
to a large company you're immediately
set up
with at least one mentor i know me i was
set up with at least three people at a
time would be a mentor
a um like a senior mentor
and then like a like buddy yes that's
what they would call it
a buddy and so it's a very robust
mentoring process and that can be very
very great for you if
you are new to this realm of
developing in a company so that can be
something that is very attractive to you
last thing about the community
this is something that's very important
to me if you came to this channel
is likely important to you but people of
color there are seven percent
black people in the software and
engineering realm
in technology there are three percent
black women
in a small company a startup let's say
the percentages are the same
for startup versus large company startup
that's seven people if you work for a
company of 100.
now for a large company if you work you
know at a
company that has 10 000 people in the
building that's significantly more
that's
700 yeah seven
700 people and so of course the
percentages are the same but
i mean i would rather get the chance to
talk with 700 black people and you know
we kick it than the seven people i don't
know i don't
that is just my thoughts on that and so
yes there is
more people of color
more um women in larger companies
because there's a larger sample size
the percentage may be the same but is
more of them so that is something to
also think about
if that's important to you the
professional development part is
something i've seen a lot of people kind
of
skip over and that's what i'm going to
mention it here with
a startup you will be working with very
innovative very
cutting edge technologies features
all the works all the bells and whistles
and they're a lot
more open to experimentation and trying
new things and so if you
like to be part of that process of
seeing you know how to implement new
features and
coding those features out and all of
that the startup may be the best place
for you
because in a big company again
they have been here long before you came
around
they're not just about to switch their
languages and frameworks just because
you are here
they will be using the same languages
they've been using since the stone ages
and all of that
so it's something to think about when
looking at
these two different companies and on top
of that
with the startup you can actually
envision yourself actually coding out
these features because they don't exist
yet you know what i mean like they are
still
in the development stages they're still
working on building things from the
ground
up while with a big company it's been
there
and you just need to make sure it stays
there and so really you're maintaining
that code instead of building things up
so in terms of
feeling like you're really having a true
impact around you
a startup might be better however
and this is for me what kind of steered
me away
from startups even though i would
honestly love to be there at some point
is there's not a very robust
learning structure you come there
great sit down we need this feature
there's not really many people to train
you there's not really many
training materials created for you shoot
you may be the person
who's creating those learning materials
for the people after you
so if you're a person who really needs
structure
because you're new at this because you
know you
are still learning and processing things
then that's when you kind of need to see
what's more important
because for me that's really what i
focused on
was shoot i don't know
i'm sorry i cannot and so the idea of
being put
in an environment like that was very
terrifying for
me but i know if i was put in that
environment i would have grown
so quickly so quickly because i would
have been forced to
learn quickly and use that on the job so
so rapidly so i know
that my trajectory and my growth would
have been
like nothing else but then for me my
stress would have also been like nothing
else
and then lastly mobility with the
startup if you want to switch jobs
you gotta start that job hunt all over
again and you gotta really actually pack
your bags and go
with a large company if you want to
change jobs you can just say to your
boss look i want to work with xnx
technology instead i want to
work with a team that works on
automation
and robotics and i know you have that
division down in texas
i want to go there and that can be a
much smoother
transition and easier way to do that and
it just was because of a conversation
also thinking about not just
business units but also locations if you
care about being able to switch
locations but also don't want to do that
legwork of
looking for a job each time a large
company may be great because they have
locations everywhere if you want to go
to dubai
go go okay it's not that easy
but you see where i'm going with this
you have a lot more flexibility and
mobility
with a larger company of course people
need to trust you of course people need
to
say you've been doing a good job and can
actually contribute to your teams
in different ways and all of that but if
you can
then having a conversation about
locations you want to change or business
you want to change
could be no problem don't forget to
subscribe to my channel and follow me on
instagram at the black female engineer
and thanks so much for watching i look
forward to seeing you all
soon bye y'all